this year's ads once again stole the
limelight from many viewers retail giant
L brands called on its Victoria Secret
Angels to feel some buzz during the big
game a knows known to walk down a runway
in six-inch heels while wearing two
million dollar fantasy bras show the
world that they know how to really play
ball
that was a nice arm all right joining us
this morning is Victoria's Secret Angel
Adriana Lima's she is live in Las Vegas
one of the many cities where Victoria's
Secret is launching its Valentine's Day
marketing push in fact the Superbowl ad
as it has in years past is meant to push
their Victoria's Victoria there
Valentine's Day marketing okay Adriana
first off what kind of reaction did you
get from the Super Bowl ads on Sunday
well I was very excited to be part of
this Super Bowl commercial and just to
know now I heard you guys talking that
it was the most-watched Super Bowl ever
over 40 million people so that is
unbelievable to be part of the
commercial and with it end with Victoria
Secrets it's one of my favorite brands
to work with they definitely make the
most impact on the commercials and in my
career they helped me tremendously
especially being part of this commercial
so definitely it was exciting it is
exciting and I know it's launched many a
career being in commercials like this
has launched many a career of other
models how different was it Adriana to
work on this campaign versus the one in
prior years with Victoria's Secret well
the difference is like the last
commercial that I did it's that we did
actually for the Super Bowl with
Victoria's Secret was 2008 and I was
alone in the commercial this year we had
all the Angels together and besides us
being together the commercial commercial
definitely I'm sure he was one of the
most watched commercials for the whole
Super Bowl yeah so to be part of it it's
I am speechless I'm speechless well
we'll give us this answer though heed
Rihanna look others Victoria's Secret
models have gone on to great success but
Gisele of course a number
among them the Tyra Banks as well as
Heidi Klum do you have aspirations to
not only be as big as them but also earn
as much as them images l earned 47
million dollars last year well it's it's
wonderful to see somebody from my
hometown from Brazil you know to be
successful internationally I'm very
proud I'm very proud and thanks to her
she opened so many doors for any other
models as well internationally so I'm
very grateful to her where she what she
did for us all right Adriana thank you
so much Adriana Lima Victoria's Secret
Angel